okay
step one
i've got my boundary in place one over x
it's not included so i'm going to leave
it above it no problems okay i've
included my asymptotes because the
boundary obeys the asymptotes okay so x
equals zero y equals zero
y is greater than one over x thinking
directionally what are you gonna
actually conclude from this
above very good okay now above makes
sense when you're looking to say
something like this
right
you can go ahead you can test a point
and convince yourself that's for example
okay for example what's a point you
might pick
this is um
this is one one this is one one on the
boundary right so if i test it out say
two one or one two either of them will
be fine okay don't go anywhere let's
finish this okay so that's all good
now
obviously because the boundary keeps on
going forever you don't cross over here
so something different must happen over
here because the boundary is defined
it's just that the boundary stopped and
it had to start again okay now again you
told me
above right that's what my intuition
says directly so looking at this and
then looking at this
one might conclude well
these points are all above and there's
an asymptote here right i can't cross
this asymptote so it seems pretty
sensible that
i can't cross this asymptote either
but
tell me
pick a point for me it's got to be in
here
how about minus one minus one
one i don't wanna be on like an
asymptote or something like that just i
want to be completely obvious right so
if the x value is minus one uh i'm going
to have one is greater than one over
negative one is it true
it is true
it works in fact i can blow right past
this horizontal asymptote and you can
tell me why
ah bingo thank you so much horizontal
asymptotes right where are horizontal
asymptotes relevant answer at positive
and negative infinity at enormous values
what relevance do horizontal and oblique
acids have in the middle none right so i
can go straight to it
done